las vegas continues to bounce back and
that means a return of shows like cirque
du soleil
and one of the group's flagship shows oh
is marking its return to the stage
tonight with a very special performance
sasha loftus joining us now live from
the bellagio with more on today's
celebration
sasha denise we just wrapped up today's
celebration
inside the casino here at bellagio and
what a celebration
it was we had the entire cast of oh
coming through here all through the
casino
with a crowd of people cheering and
really holding signs welcoming back
oh which as you said is one of cirque's
flagship
shows now most of the crowd from that
parade has kind of
walked on here but there's still a few
people left as they again wrap up that
celebration here inside the casino
now kicked off right at five o'clock we
had a carousel horse
leading it and the entire cast and crew
following behind to
really kind of perform wave to people in
the crowd it was really a great
experience
now we've seen a lot of shows returned
to the strip since last year's pandemic
shutdown
but this one is especially significant
as it is a flagship performance for mgm
oh has held more than 10 thousand shows
in front of about
17 million guests now back out here live
the party will continue
for a little while longer even though as
i said that parade just wrapped up
mgm leaders will make a few remarks and
then we'll get a chance to speak with
the cast of crew
ks and crew rather around six o'clock
tonight we'll of course
keep you posted both on air and online
we've been live streaming this event as
well so
make sure to catch that on our 8 news
now facebook page for now reporting live
at the bellagio sasha loftis
8 news now